but first for you a fox news alert joe
biden's transition team has just
released a statement it is attributed to
hunter biden and it reads this way
quote i learned yesterday for the first
time that the u.s attorney's office in
delaware advised my legal counsel
also yesterday that they are
investigating my tax affairs
i take this matter very seriously but i
am confident that a professional and
objective review of these matters
will demonstrate that i handled my
affairs legally and appropriately
including with the benefit of
professional tax advisors
end quote well a few of us knew that
already to be honest
shortly before last month's election we
reported on this show that federal
prosecutors had opened a criminal
investigation
into hunter biden's business dealings
with china among other countries
we knew that was true which is why we
said it other news organizations knew it
was true too
but they didn't say it they said nothing
they hid that news critically relevant
news
from their readers and their viewers
they didn't want to hurt joe biden's
chances of getting elected
the justice department itself refused to
confirm the existence of that
investigation
for fear of being accused of political
interference
so going into election day most
americans had no idea any of this was
going on
all they knew was that joe biden had
dismissed the entire thing
as a russian plot and that large numbers
of senior officials in the so-called
intelligence community
agreed with that assessment that's what
joe biden said at the debate
again what we're about to play for you
is the sum
total of information that most voters in
this country got
about the biden family's business
dealings with china in the weeks before
they made up their minds
in this election watch there are
50 former national intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian
plant they have said that this is has
all the care
four five former heads of the cia both
parties
say what he's saying is a bunch of
garbage nobody believes it except
of his and his good friend rudy gianni
oh so 50 former intelligence folks have
decided
that it's russian garbage it's just more
slavic disinformation just another
example of the kremlin interfering in
our sacred democracy
the intel community has decided that so
just throw it in the circular file
well that's a familiar line you've heard
it many times before in fact you heard
it every day for years
russia yet somehow you haven't heard it
much recently
in fact for about a month and eight days
to be exact
democrats have about zero interest in
highlighting russian meddling in this
election
assuming there was any russian meddling
it was not very effective
apparently vladimir putin let down his
closest friend just when it counted
poignant in fact the whole topic of
foreign interference
no longer seems like a priority for the
democratic party have you noticed why
because it's now clear to everyone
whether they're willing to admit it or
not
that the real threat to this country is
not russia
it hasn't been russia for 30 years since
the summer of 1991 when the soviet union
collapsed and to claim otherwise
is absurd and was always absurd the
truth
is that the real threat we face as a
country is from the communist government
of
china which and everyone knows this too
has long been in bed with our democratic
elites in some cases
literally in bed and yes we're looking
at you eric swalwell you
lying creep more on him in just a minute
but back to tonight's news on the biden
family how do we know for sure that
hunter biden is under federal
investigation where'd the news come from
well it came directly from the biden
transition team they're the ones who
told us
the confirmation of this investigation
was not leaked to the new york times it
came right from the top of the
democratic party
in fact in tonight's statement there was
included a message from joe biden
himself
affirming that he is quote deeply proud
of his son
joe biden didn't specify why he was so
gosh darn proud of hunter biden
maybe federal investigations are a rite
of passage in the biden family
we can only speculate we can be pretty
sure that joe biden didn't want to issue
the statement in the first place
why would he who would want to issue it
he issued it because he was pushed
by whom and for what purpose was he
pushed
that's the question tonight now we don't
know the answer to that
we do know that there are powerful
forces within the democratic party
that do not like joe biden they believe
joe biden is too male and too
white and too wedded to the old ways
wedded to politics as it
used to be back when there was a
functioning constitution that provided
checks and balances
on power people like that would like to
displace
joe biden and get right to the part of
the story where kamala harris and her
sponsors at google
run the united states of america and
it's hard to believe they're going to
wait four years to do that
we'll see you heard it here first
according to what we've learned tonight
from the statement
the investigation into hunter biden is
not related to his drug use we confirmed
that
as well instead the investigation is
based in part on suspicious
activity reports on foreign transactions
now keep in mind in the weeks before the
election you were not allowed to go on
twitter or facebook and discuss those
suspicious foreign transactions
you couldn't talk about them even after
hunter biden's business associates
people like tony babilinski came forward
in public with evidence
that those were real you had to be quiet
and not tell your neighbors about any of
it
in case your neighbors might be tempted
not to vote for joe biden once they
learned it
and they might have been tempted not to
vote for joe biden had they known
on this show tony tony bobolinsky
revealed that hunter biden made deals
with groups connected directly to the
communist party of china
and he made those deals with the
blessing of his father explicitly the
former vice president joe biden
who himself was profiting from those
deals directly
the former vice president has said he
had no knowledge whatsoever of his son's
business dealings and was not involved
in them at all
but this sounds like direct involvement
in them yeah that's a blatant lie when
he states that that is a blatant lie
obviously the world's aware that i
attended the debate last thursday
and in that debate he made a specific
statement
around questions around this from the
president
and i'll be honest with you i almost
stood up and screamed liar
and walked out because i was shocked
that after
four days or five days that they prepped
for this that the biden family is taking
that position
to the world again that was tony
babilinski
who was in business with hunter biden
who met with joe biden to discuss that
business
with china that's what he said
on camera and at the time they called it
a conspiracy theory
cena rolled its eyes so literally they
dismissed it as
russian disinformation most media
outlets deemed it unworthy of mentioning
at all
now it turns out all of them were lying
again if you're looking for
election rigging look no further
that's what this is they kept
information from the public
in order to influence the outcome of the
election
they rigged it a few good reporters have
been vindicated tonight starting with
the tough but beleaguered staff of the
new york post who took a massive amount
of crap for telling the truth